for nearly a decade my collaborators and
I at the self-assembly lab have been
working on material systems that
transform themselves assemble themselves
and adapt to their environment from our
early work on 4d printing where we
printed objects dipped them under water
and they transformed to our active
August at respond to temperature and
sunlight to our more recent work on
active textiles that respond to body
temperature and change porosity to our
rapid liquid printing worker we print
inflatable structures that morph based
on air pressure and go from one shape to
another or our self-assembly work where
we dipped objects underwater they
respond to wave energy and assemble
themselves and to precise objects like
furniture or at larger scales using wind
energy we have metre diameter weather
balloons that assemble in the airspace
above a construction site for dangerous
environments or harsh extreme places
where it's hard to get people or
equipment they can assemble in the
airspace and as the helium dies they
then come back to the ground and you're
left with a big space frame structure
all of this research is about taking
simple materials activating them with
forces in their environment gravity wind
waves temperature sunlight and getting
them to perform getting them to
transform assemble etc how do we build
smart things without complex
electromechanical devices but more
recently we were approached by a group
in the Maldives and they were interested
in taking some of this research and ways
of thinking and applying it to some of
the challenges that they've faced in
terms of climate change and the first
thing that you do when you're approached
by someone the Maldives is say you want
to go on a site visit it is amazing so
we went there and I actually walked away
with a really different perspective on
the future of climate change because you
would imagine you know the Maldives are
sinking they're screwed what are they
going to do but I walked away thinking
they actually might be the model the
future model of the built environment
where they can adapt and be resilient
rather than
fixed man-made infrastructure but
there's typically three main approaches
to sea level rise and climate change one
of them is that we can do nothing and we
can run away and that's a pretty bad
idea as more than 40% of the world's
population is living in coastal areas as
sea levels rise and as storms get worse
and worse we're going to be more and
more underwater so it's imperative that
we solve this pretty demanding problem
the second is that we can build barriers
we can build walls the problem here is
that we take a static solution trying to
fight against a super dynamic high
energy problem and nature is almost
always going to win so that's likely not
going to work either
the third approach is using dredging so
dredging is where you suck up a bunch of
sand from the deep ocean and you pump it
back onto the beaches if you go to any
Beach around the Northeast or or western
coast you'll see that they use dredging
year after year after year just to
survive it's really not a good solution
in the Maldives they do the same thing
and they can build an island in a month
a brand new island they build from
dredging but it's really really bad for
the marine ecosystem and then they
become addicted to dredging they need to
do that year after year but in the time
that it took them to build that one
island three sandbars built themselves
and these are massive amounts of sand so
big you can park your boat on it and
this is what's called a site visit it's
really hard work in Boston winters this
is massive amounts of sand that
naturally accumulates just based on the
forces the waves and the ocean
topography so we started the study that
why do sandbars form if we could tap
into that we could understand it and we
could utilize it it's based on the
amount of energy in the ocean and the
topography in the landscape that
promotes sand accumulation so what we're
proposing is to work with the forces of
nature to build rather than destroy and
in my lab at MIT we set up a wave tank a
big tank that's pumping waves and we
place geometries underwater we tried all
sorts of different geometries the waves
interact with the geometry and then
create turbulence and start to
accumulate the sand so the sand starts
to form these sand bars on their own
here's an aerial view on the
left-hand side you'll see the beach
that's growing in the middle you'll see
the sandbar that formed so these are
geometries that collaborate with the
force of the wave to build we then
started the fabricate one this was in
February in Boston we have large rolls
of canvas it's a biodegradable material
a super cheap easy to work with we then
sew it into these large bladders and
then we flew over there and I know what
you're thinking this is not the fire
festival this is real life it's real and
we flew there with these canvas bladders
in our suitcases we got sunburned
because it was Boston winter and then we
fill them with sand and we place them
underwater these are exactly the same
geometries that you saw in the tank
they're just human scale large objects
filled with sand we place them
underwater they're just really simple
geometries in the front of them you'll
see it's clear water the waves are
crashing over it's quite clear and then
on the back side there's turbulence the
water and the sand is mixing up it's
causing sediment transport and then the
sand is accumulating you'll see some
friendly stingrays here the visited us
on the left is day one the right is day
three you'll see the sand ripples in the
light areas where the sand is
accumulating just after two days so this
was last February and it's very much
ongoing work this is just in the
beginning of this research over the next
year and longer we're going to be
studying this through satellite imagery
and bathymetry data to understand what
the short-term and long-term impacts are
of natural sand accumulation in the
environment and the bigger vision though
is that we want to build submersible
geometries almost like submarines that
we can sink and float like adaptable
artificial reefs you could deploy them
if there's a storm coming from one
direction or another or if the seasons
are changing you can use these adaptable
reef structures to use the force of
waves to accumulate sand and we think
this could be used in many coastal
regions and many island nations around
the world but when we think about
building smarter environments think of
smarter buildings or smarter cars or
smarter clothing that typically means
adding more power more batteries more
devices more cost more complete
city and ultimately more failure so
we're always trying to think about how
do we build smarter things with less how
do we build smarter things that are
simple and so what we're proposing at
the lab and with this project
specifically is to use simple materials
like sand that collaborates with forces
in the environment like waves to
accumulate and adapt we'd like to work
with you collaborate with us to develop
this to scale it and apply this way of
thinking we think it's a different model
for climate change one that's about
adaptation and resilience rather than
resistance and fear so help us turn
natural destruction into natural
construction thank you
[Applause]